in a region that's home to nearly 60% of
the global population 2024 will be an
opportunity for many to choose new
leaders and
governments but with so many different
political systems is there any Common
Thread that voters should bear in mind I
think the key here is access to power
but also how power is exercise and
whether the exercise of power uh has
legitimacy to to hold on to hang on the
largest democracy in the world India
votes in April and May recent State
elections suggest prime minister
Narendra Modi has a good chance of a
third term but his critics say he's
taken India down an authoritarian path
that's concerned many who fear he could
further erode Democratic
institutions in Bangladesh political
violence is expected ahead of the polls
opening in early January shik casena the
longest serving female head of
government could take a fifth term as PM
but the United Nations has urged the
police to refrain from excessive force
and mass arrests ahead of the
vote Pakistan could also see contentious
elections in February with one former
prime minister in jail and another
recently returned from Exile the
democratic system is likely to undergo a
severe test but some say a flawed
democracy is better than no democracy at
all without polls the alternatives are
worse we have military coup uh military
government in Myanmar we had military
government in Thailand and in in most
other countries if you don't have uh the
people people's ability uh to voice a
preferences uh then is is
worse age is on the balance in Indonesia
but it's the young not the old who are
calling the tune more than 50% of the
electorate under the age of 40 although
continuity and stability may be at the
front of many voters minds and all eyes
will be on one of Asia's most
Progressive democracies Taiwan when it
votes for a new
president Democratic institutions have
thrived in recent decades but the
biggest player could be taiwan's
undemocratic neighbor China and its
threats to take back what it claims is a
renegade Province Tony Chang Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer